never write love is over or is it  Atlas fans with keen eyes have noticed  that your personified protagonist and on  bears some similarities to the love pair  of Kathryn queue DLC costumes themed on  atlases puzzle climbing hit while on  dawns the outfits of the title character  Makoto gets to wear the more  conservative clothes of Catherine with a  K and wrapping up this batch are the  Messiah's judge type personas that pack  a punch  you guys to weaklings be a [ __ ]  [Music]  the denial  go down  alright let me handle this  [Music]  weaklings pray what if you remaining  [Music]  let's go yeah victory  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  have you been sporting alternate duds to  get a dlc refresher check out our  YouTube channel and give us a like and  subscribe while you're there thanks for  watching